moving on to other news now and fighting
in and around the Libyan Capital has
caused at least 20 injuries
the latest gun battles began after a
prominent Commander was captured by
rival
faction's forces control much of Tripoli
warring factions have battled for
control of the country since Muammar
Gaddafi was deposed and killed 12 years
ago let's bring in our correspondent
Malik trainer who's joining us live from
Tripoli we're hearing that the fighting
the fighting that's been a result of
this Commander's capture is the worst in
Tripoli in months Malik what's happening
there
well that's exactly right Tripoli has
seen relative calm since the last time
last year when violence erupted
look at the end of the day people are
suffering due to the lack of
accountability towards these powerful
armed groups here in Tripoli that both
of these groups the specialty term force
and the 444th Brigade are under the
umbrella of the security apparatus they
are funded by the Libyan government so
people are extremely angry as their
ongoing clashes sporadic we can hear
sporadic gunfire uh every every every
every 10 to 15 minutes we can we can
clearly hear them we've heard even The
Echoes of heavy artillery being used so
uh you know people are extremely angry
we've seen just recently in the last 20
or 30 minutes uh the red crescent the
European red crescent say that they've
been able to uh evacuate about dozens
dozens of families from the areas of
clashes but for now these clashes are
still ongoing and people uh innocent
people innocent civilians are being
caught in the crossfire yeah again
clashes that are taking place we're
hearing in areas that are quite densely
populated what are Libyan officials
doing to de-escalate the situation Malik
well the prime minister is currently in
a meeting with military and security
officials he's trying to negotiate a
ceasefire between these two armed groups
but he has yet neither the Prime
Minister the chief of staff of the
military or the presidential Council
release a statement towards the violence
that is happening reassuring people and
that's made residents here extremely
angry but we have seen a a statement
released by the U.N support Mission also
the U.S embassy has recently uh just a
few minutes ago released a statement
calling for the immediate de-escalation
and for the parties to to uh to to stop
fighting and protect civilians uh I mean
look the situation Tripoli is can get
very tense very quickly and these
incidents just prove that a a nationwide
agreement needs to happen where these
armed groups are are become loyal to
Libyan institutions and not towards
themselves of you know 20 people injured
so far and the fear is that if a
solution isn't agreed upon real soon the
situation could escalate and there'll be
more people uh more more people will
suffer uh while these two people these
two groups continue fighting Malik thank
you very much for that mileage trainer
with the latest live in Tripoli well
let's take a closer look at the two most
powerful factions that have been
fighting in the Libyan Capital the 444
Brigade controls large parts of Southern
Tripoli its leader Mahmud Hamza was
detained by its rival the special
deterrent Force whose stronghold is
matiga International Airport and
controls parts of Southern Tripoli this
sparked the latest round of violence and
both groups are backed by the UN
recognized government in Tripoli well
let's get more on this now we're joined
by anas El gomati he's the director of
the Southwick Institute it's a think
tank focusing on Libya and he's joining
us live from Istanbul uh good to see you
Mr gomartie firstly can you tell us a
little bit more about Mahmoud Hamza and
why he's been captured
well he has an enormous standing amongst
his Brigade The 444 but also I think he
blurs the lines between the political
factions that have been largely at peace
for the last year in Tripoli and their
allegiances towards the government of
national Unity as it stands under Abdul
Hamid the Weber and those that favor a a
Unity government or an elite bargain
with no other than Khalifa haftar The
the Renegade General that has been
behind many of these same kind of
conflicts over the last several years
those that are on the ground and that
know Hamza quite well would suggest that
he is in the anti-hato faction and you
know behind the scenes of this latest
episode of the conflict hanza has been
quite formidable in negotiations in the
Rival five plus five military talks that
we're supposed to unify Libya's rival
factions over the last several years he
has been a thorn in in the negotiations
against Hafner and I think the timing is
quite curious about why he was picked up
in matiga International Airport only in
the last 24 hours so he's standing not
only in Tripoli but amongst other
Brigade trades that have similar
sympathies I think it's quite telling
okay so a person of great importance
we're hearing that efforts by top
government and army officials to have
him freed have failed what is it that
the special deterrence Force wants
well I think it goes back to what the
larger picture of these negotiations and
there are negotiations that have been
going on for several months now to unify
the Rival military factions under the
gnu in Tripoli but also those aligned
with the LNA and the khalifafter and I
think why Mahmoud hamza's position not
only in Tripoli in the southern part of
Tripoli is so important but if we look
at where the fighting has extended to
over the last 24 hours they're not just
you know run-of-the-mill Libyan towns
and cities
these are areas that are under the
control of the 444 and and they're
expanding towards those areas but
they're also critical supply lines and
supply lines are everything in the
conquest for Tripoli was that these were
the key parts that were held by khalifah
when he took over or tried to attempt to
take Tripoli in that paragraph in April
2019 so when the when the war is move to
these places they're they're more
telling they're telling that the 444 is
not only influential in Tripoli it's
influential in the parts of the country
that will determine the Fates of the
capital okay and I think that's why this
timing is so curious okay we're already
seeing the worst fighting in Tripoli in
months as a result of hamza's capture
what will it take to de-escalate the
situation now
well sadly the moving the moving of the
conflict towards the most densely
populated parts of the trip of the
capital are not enough for either the
government of national Unity that has
frankly not done enough and its ability
to call off the fighting but also for
the UN and International Community that
have always been a little bit late and
when they're a little bit late it always
tells me that some people are involved
at the highest levels both
internationally and domestically and
know that there is a power move on the
hand conflicts like this in the past
regretfully as bad as they get it's not
the humanitarian toll it's not the
tragedy that unfolds it's phone calls
that are made at the highest levels from
members of of the International
Community that tell those factions to
pull out otherwise they might be
sanctioned or their finances might be
Frozen and I think that's where this
that's where probably this conflict will
most likely end or most likely end when
someone makes a phone call and ends it
and that's that's a regretful part of
the the near 13 years of conflicts in
Libya it's never the humanitarian at all
that is it meets the threshold it's
always it's always the phone calls that
decide it Mr gometti it's great to get
your perspective on this we really
appreciate it that is anas El gomati of
the South Institute live in Istanbul